[Music]
Everything is rumbling from there and now
I'm stuck and can't get out,
so this is really like this.
[Music] I know the
facts about this situation are
a bit more
[music]
and
people are a bit too crowded now, so
I know the cops and supply groups are having a hard time, but I
wasn't prepared
[music]  ]
Above all, it is important to identify the cause of the accident and
prevent similar accidents. We will
thoroughly investigate the cause of the accident in this book and
fundamentally improve
it so that the same accident does not recur in the future.  It
wasn't a problem that could have been solved by doing it, and now I'm figuring it out.
Also, as you know well yesterday,
there were various riots and demonstrations in various places in Seoul, so there was an aspect that the
police and security forces
were dispersed to these places.
[Music]
[Music]  ]